Good morning, Hank, it's Wednesday and this
is the beginning of my zombie apocalypse novella:
"Pre-zombification, my father was already
obsessed with corn. He told me almost every
day that corn was in control of us. Corn wants
the world to contain more corn, so corn evolves
us to agree with it: Corn tells us that we
could make sugar out of corn, or fuel out
of corn, or plastic out of corn, etc. The
flu makes us cough, which spreads the flu.
Corn makes us corn-hungry, which spreads corn.
He got this idea from a book, and he never
ceased to be amazed by it. For years, he would
talk about it. We’d be eating mashed potatoes
or something, and he’d say, “You know,
potatoes are impossible without corn. That
corn, it’s everywhere.” (He meant this
metaphorically, although it is now nearly
true literally.)
I think my dad was so fascinated by this idea
because he realized on some fundamental level
that he was not in control of his desires:
I think he woke up every morning in his nice
house with hardwood floors and granite countertops
and wondered why he desired granite countertops
and hardwood floors, wondered who precisely
was running his life. Most people never stop
to wonder why they like Pop Tarts or rainflow
showerheads or skinny girls or whatever it
is they like. Although my father never abandoned
the narrowly circumscribed suburban life he
was fated to desire, the why of it all nagged
at him. I inherited that penchant for intellectualism,
a character flaw that these days can only
be thoroughly eradicated by getting Z’ed
up.
Anyway, I have been thinking about the old
man because it was a year ago today that I
shot him in the chest with a hollow-point
.45 caliber bullet. He kind of smiled as he
fell backwards onto the overstuffed living
room couch. He took a minute to die, and it
was the smilingest minute I’d ever seen
from him.
A lot of the Z’ed up smile when you kill
them. I don’t know if they’re grateful
or amused or what, but it helps with the guilt,
which quite a lot of people feel. I knew a
kid once who was the kind of sentimentalist
who found it troubling to think of himself
as a murderer, so he called killing Zs completing
them. I liked that.
That kid—his name was Marcos Marcos—got
Z’ed up somehow. We were living in a very
nice heavily chandeliered Lincoln Park townhouse
with a few other humanoid types, and then
one morning Marcos Marcos made a go at my
puppy, Mr. President, and I had to complete
him. I completed his head all over the dining
room credenza of that fancy townhouse and
then me and Mr. President bolted out for the
proverbial higher ground.
Newzies go for dogs and cats and cows first,
because they’ve still got enough of a moral
compass to recognize that separating human
beings from their vital organs—aside from
being ethically troubling—is cannibalistic.
It is my own moral compass that has done me
in now, working through the last few gallons
of the gas that runs the generator that pumps
the putrid Z’ed out air down here into my
Lincoln Square cellar, eating through the
last rusted cans of diced tomatoes and Spam,
drinking very expensive red wine at the rate
of precisely one bottle per day, watching
the shelves empty out, wondering—as my father
did—what terrible monster lurking inside
of me forces me to go on rowing against the
current when I could just walk up a staircase,
unlock this cellar door, and get Z’ed up
like a normal person."
So, Hank, that's the first page of my zombie
apocalypse novella which will never be published,
not because I dislike zombie apocalypse novellas
but because mine is BAD. That's by far the
best page of it, it gets much worse from there.
However, the only copy of my zombie apocalypse
novella that will ever exist will be just
one of many amazing Project For Awesome raffle
prizes. Speaking of which, Nerdfighters, I
hope you're hard at work on your Project For
Awesome videos. If you want to know more about
what the Project For Awesome is, look in my
points. (points rapidly)
Hank, I don't want to give too much away but
on December seventeenth and eighteenth Project
For Awesome videos are going to be featured
ALL OVER YOUTUBE so Nerdfighters make those
Project For Awesome videos awesome. DFTBA
like it says on my shirt, Hank, I'll see you
on Friday.